before we continue I'd like to give a
shout out to this video sponsor last
Claudia last Claudia is a mobile RPG
game that features real-time battle with
an enormous world view and a magnificent
plot that depicts humans collaborating
with monsters to save the world together
it has classically pixelated characters
moving about in a 3d environment with
flashy moves to match with detail
adventure cutscenes personally I loved
how the lore of various item
descriptions arcs and units are all
intertwine with each other right now you
can own three thousand crystals through
the beginners welcome campaign so if
you'd like to check out the game click
the link in the description and download
the game for free I'd argue that in most
cases the villains just as important as
the hero in anime after all a compelling
hero's useless without opposition
thankfully the past decades given us
many iconic villains and for this week's
edition of the top 10 lists we're going
through some of the best before we enter
a new year and a new decade let's take a
look at some of the most compelling
badass or entertaining anime villains of
the past decade
[Music]
sugu Monsieur since all their days we
start off with the war obsessed villain
from Helsing the major now his scheme
set the foundation for the stories
conflicts few can match how deranged the
major is as someone who loves all
aspects of war the consequences of war
didn't matter much to him nor which side
he ended up on as long as there's
bloodshed it's enough to satisfy this
crazy villain then again what else could
you expect from the commander of Nazi
vampires hell bent on the destruction of
London even Alucard at his worst doesn't
come close to how sick and terrible the
major can be ironically for someone who
loves war so much the major is actually
a terrible fighter nevertheless his
masterful maneuvering and manipulations
get him the ending that he wants despite
his plans not completely sticking the
major exits the stage of Helsing of
Victor a fulfilled and happy man
soon you naughty cedar
[Music]
as a long series with the legacy it has
it's no surprise that one piece has its
own colorful and intriguing villains
among those doflamingo is arguably my
favorite his glasses his overall aura
his quotable speeches there's a lot to
like about doflamingo he's intimidating
and entertaining despite being a
powerful threat to our heroes and let's
not forget his creativity with his
powers it helps that he is one of the
few villains in media whose backstories
don't completely redeem him yes he was
abused and had a typical sob story
background but I'd argue that doflamingo
was already a dick to begin with anyway
his experiences merely drove him further
into villainy and I think that's one
detail that we can appreciate with how
his character gets developed
kornel circle your course Lala
[Music]
if I were to describe taka sugi in one
word I'd use
charisma a brooding figure the enigmatic
takasugi served as the primary villain
in the series up to the introduction of
boots or at least nevertheless I'd say
the former still the more appealing
between the two one good thing in my
opinion about taka Suki is that his
backstory and motives were kept in the
dark for most of his story at first he
seems to be a one-dimensional edgy
villain known for his goal of revenge
against the world a character only being
kept aloft by fangirls then comes his
backstory and we find out there's really
more to this villain than meets the eye
he's truly a good example of a victim of
circumstance I guarantee that I'm not
alone in the camp of people whose
perspective of him changed after seeing
the story from his point of view solo
kisses Aoki a room under the beauty of
Psychopaths
is that it's a series that strikes home
quite a bit and it certainly makes you
think about the repercussions of some
systems of the real worlds personally
speaking I find psycho passes work quite
dystopia in some angles which is why
makishima at one point comes across as a
very interesting character sent with the
goal to liberate society from the Sibyl
system he presents himself as a Dark
Messiah blessed with enlightenment his
natural charisma attracts numerous
followers and he masterfully organizes
murders in his quest to overthrow the
Sibyl system the greatest evil from his
point of view despite all of his
parading as a savior he basically just
does things out of a personal vendetta
this character is especially relevant in
modern society considering that he's a
product of a world and a society that
denied him his right to exist
not too different from the newest
incarnation of Joker hey
I thought communal yeah that's it now
here's a wild card of a villain ek
buckaroos and knowledge brokers a simple
character a manipulative and sleazy
person who enjoys chaos and conflict
while he's a villain through and through
he goes about his business in a more
affable way being more of a bystander
who loves witnessing chaos consume
people and their resulting reactions
let's just say that ESI is a troll more
than anything else a chaotic neutral one
that you're better off avoiding if you
value your sanity needless to say this
puts immer odds with the blunt and
abrasive Shizuo who sees him for what he
is finally meeting his match he finds
the blonde man a worthy rival and their
battles are legends all over the busy
ward
[Music]
wait a Jojo representative in a top ten
list that isn't do what madness is this
well listen just hear me out for a while
make no mistake do is a very
entertaining villain because of how
over-the-top he is the cartoonishly evil
stint and the feud with Jonathan's : or
but have you ever taken a good look at
Kira I believe Kira is a far more
compelling villain because of how unique
he is for a serial killer Kira's neither
a super genius nor batshit insane
instead he's just a plain old murderer
no justifications no conscience he's
just a villain given powers and acting
on his instincts the scary part of this
is how relatable Kira can be everyone at
some point has just wanted a quiet life
he doesn't have a grand motivation in
doing the things he's doing he's just
following his instincts and his own
mental desires we even see the story
from his perspective and I think that
makes Kira a great villain
representative for the Jo Jo series
Vinland sog has been picking up steam as
expected and it's in large part due to
its compelling villain asked aloud in a
series about Vikings you'd expect the
antagonist to be a badass rugged man
with overwhelming power you know
probably a burly man that doesn't give a
damn and just lays anything while
looking cool that description is not
completely wrong for ask alot but it's
not exactly right either what makes him
so dangerous isn't his overwhelming
power although he's no slouch in that
department either I think a skill adds
key trait is his ability to read people
he's a master of deception and you have
to be at the top of your game when
facing him one wrong read and ask elad
will gladly make you pay overall he's a
lot more complex than he seems this
makes him a dangerous foe that often
must overcome but even go as far as to
say that he's been more of a main
character than toughen himself
chicken gotcha
coming sky Rocco
once more we welcome Madara to another
list when I first heard of the legendary
leader of the Uchiha my expectations
were off the roof as he made his
appearance in the great ninja war those
expectations were met and then some the
entered the war as expected a well-oiled
machine of destruction
no one came close to matching his
strength tactics and power mastery from
the onset which is one of the greatest
one-man army fights and shown him by the
way all the way to his battles against
the main guys mother--i didn't
disappoint as expected from someone that
has been built up in the way he was I'd
say that the way he was defeated was a
bit of a cop-out though it's as if ki
she realized that he made mother are too
powerful already so he just conveniently
disposed of him
suck
of course eysan has to find his way back
into one of these lists again bleach has
been finished for quite some time
already but has there been a lot of
villains with a legacy like Aizen
throughout these years besides his
broken powers and seemingly endless
transformations aizen's most known from
mind games his powers of illusion
already play to that few can outmaneuver
Aizen in a battle of wits whatever plan
or strategy you bring say goodbye to it
as Aizen will have a counter to it
whether it be a carefully crafted plan
or the simple act of overpowering
whatever you have with his superior
reiatsu few can stand against Aizen at
the top of his game ad immortality and
overly tuned combat abilities to his
superior intellect and have a formidable
opponent you get some nice development
angles centered on his loneliness at the
top I'm sure what most people know Aizen
for are his broken abilities and the
insatiable desire for control and power
he's truly a once-in-a-lifetime villain
and it's not surprising that the
downfall of bleach began when he went
down standing tall at the top is Mara
Webb the main villain of hunter hunters
Chimaera and Ark finds himself at the
top as a perfect antithesis to our
protagonists the strongest chimera ant
maryam's a ruthless beast who knows no
mercy
none more blatant than his actions on
his debut episode the great thing about
maryam is his development starting off
as the ace that gives no value to life
he slowly develops into a complete
character despite starting off as a
sociopath the Maryam you see by the end
of the arc is a completely different and
complex character by all means as his
experiences with the rest of the world
accumulate he eventually starts leaning
towards becoming a character that still
a villain for now carries some
justification for his actions in the end
it can be argued that marrow rooms the
key character in the Chimera ant are
it's his development that we see and
follow after all now that's something
that not all villains can make a claim
to other villains might match Maryam in
some areas such as outright popularity
for having this much development and
complexity is something that sets the
chimera and King apart from a lot of
anime villains this decade so what do
you think about this list for me these
are some of the top anime villains of
the past decade to be honest there are a
lot more characters that I'd include
perhaps if this gets 5,000 likes we can
go on for a volume - who knows
who's your favorite villain of this
decade comment below and let me know if
you enjoyed the video please leave a
like and subscribe to the channel for
more anime content don't forget to check
out our sponsors game last Claudia the
links in the description and I'll see
you next time on Vinny tube
[Music]
median
[Music]